rien à faire dans ces conditions les
vents soufflaient de 75 à 100 kilomètres
à l'heure
le report à jeudi du slalom géant chez
les dames n'a surpris personne
la première à s'élancer sur la piste
devait être cet athlète italienne on
voyait pas parce que le vent monte la
neige et du coup c'était pas possible
vraiment de courir
déjà hier c'était limite quand on a fait
le fisc habitué à ce que mère nature
perturbe son sport habitué à s'y ajuster
comme biais des skieurs elle reste elle
moi je suis content d'avoir peur pour
eux dans une condition au pas pareil
pour tout le monde et est bonne et on
fera quelques jours en plus
d'entraînements un froid polaire mordant
pour ceux qui le brave justine dufour
lapointe dit que cela a affecté un peu
au niveau des pieds très serré dans ses
bottes le froid et je le sentais
immédiatement ça prenait environ même
pas deux ron que mes orteils je sentais
plus mais hier se prénommant je pense
que l'adrénaline et elle est clairement
rendez-vous qui j'ai pas eu trop froid
aux pieds 9 10 degrés sous zéro c'est
raisonnable hiver mais il faut pas se
plier au mercure parce qu'ici le vent
fait chuter dramatiquement les
températures ressenties et les
bourrasques pose des problèmes
geneviève simard rappelle qu'aux jeux de
turin le vent avait forcé les
organisateurs à descendre la ligne de
départ plus bas sur la piste ce qui
arrive c'est les fanions le drapeau sur
les portes quand il prend dans le vent
l'époque peuvent plier vers le skieur
donc si on est en train de faire un
virage puis les fanions de ce pays vers
new bell à la porte on peut on peut le
prendre la porte sur la poitrine c'est
dangereux pour ça elle croit que la
fédération internationale de ski en
repoussant le slalom voulait aussi
s'assurer que la compétition soit
équitable pour toutes les participantes
la finale en slopestyle féminin est
toutefois été maintenues ce lundi mais
avec deux descentes au lieu de trois
d'ailleurs annick cette décision de
maintenir la finale de straub star
féminin est remise en question par
plusieurs athlètes
oui elles disent on ne nous a pas
écoutés ni consulté il aurait fallu
repousser les preuves et pourra citer
quelques-unes elles disent c'était
terrifiant comme course d'essai et
cumulé à une loterie
il faut dire qu'en plus de nombreuses
chutes eh bien il ya plusieurs plans un
planchiste sont arrêtés à mi parcours
parce qu'elle avait peur d'être balayé
par le vent une fois dans les airs et de
se blesser
elle déplore aussi le fait que ce n'est
pas montré leur sport son meilleur jour
pour notre analyste dominick gauthier et
mines était clair dès la première
descente
on est en train de jouer avec la vie et
la carrière des athlètes
quoi qu'en dise la fédération
internationale de ski qui assurent elles
qui n'auraient jamais maintenu cette
épreuve si la sécurité des athlètes
avaient été mises en danger avaient été
menacées annexe verront un terrain de
pyongyang merci beaucoup au revoir au
revoir